It's great to be joined today by Matt Gerth,
senior fellow at Media Matters, where his
work focuses on the Fox Trump feedback loop
news coverage of politics as well as media
ethics.
Matt, really great to have you on.
I appreciate it.
Good to be here.
So, I mean, let's just start with something
and maybe that can be the Dominion lawsuit
against Fox News.
We have, of course, been covering with great
interest for me, one of the most interesting
storylines has been yet another layer to what
goes out on the airwaves at Fox.
Doesn't necessarily match what the feelings
are among some of the hosts behind the scenes,
and that's totally fine.
But what's the bigger story, if there is one
yet about how the audience of Fox News is
reacting to this lawsuit and the leak texts?
If they are even aware of it, because this
is something I've been talking to my audience
about.
Well, will the average FOX, newer Fox News
viewer even know what it is that is going
on?
I think you've hit the nail on the head there.
That's really the question.
I mean, as we know, people who follow Fox
News are really in a bubble of right wing
media.
They are getting their news solely from outlets
like Fox.
They are disinclined to believe what they
hear from people like you and me and The New
York Times and The Washington Post and everybody
else.
And that's something that Fox has really cultivated
for decades, trying to make its viewers not
believe other sources.
I think what we are seeing, though, is some
right wing outlets are trying to get the news
out in hopes of building up their own audiences.
That internal rivalry within the right could
be causing Fox some trouble as outlets like
Newsmax try to hive off a little bit of Fox's
market share by revealing what Fox hosts and
executives were saying behind the scenes.
We know that Donald Trump has been arguing
that now Fox News isn't doing as well in the
ratings, he would argue, because they are
no longer as positive about him as they once
were.
And we'll get to the narrative about Trump
on Fox more recently.
But as far as the ratings go, is there any
truth to that claim that Fox is not doing
as well?
I don't think specifically.
It's easy to make that claim right now.
I mean, in general, there's been a drop off
in cable news viewership since the last election,
right?
I would expect that to pop up a little bit
more as we get closer to the next presidential
election.
But right now, I don't think we're seeing
a evaporation of Fox's market share due to
it.
Not supporting Trump enough, though, as we
saw in the Dominion filings, they are very,
very attuned to that possibility and are willing
to take fairly substantial action in order
to prevent that from coming to pass.
So there's a survey which suggests that about
a fifth of Fox News viewers now say they trust
the network less since the revelations from
the text messages.
This is this is pretty squishy.
It doesn't strike me as the most scientific
claim.
And there's some definitional questions here.
And how much did they trust them before?
They probably still trust Fox way more than
you or I would.
So there's sort of some squishiness here.
But if we can believe that there is a portion
of the Fox audience that is now less and less
trusting of Fox News, what specifically would
it be?
Would it be that they feel the hosts are telling
me one thing but privately believe something
else?
Or like what would be the practical belief
that's affecting them?
Yeah, that's the real question.
And something that the poll can't really get
to is, is why they trust Fox less.
Is it because they think Fox was lying to
them on TV or that they think Fox was not
sufficiently supportive privately?
Is it because Fox is too into election denial
or not intuitive enough is something we can't
really pass out of that poll, though.
I mean, I do think to a large extent what
Fox fears the most is other rivals on the
right.
And so it is bad for them if Newsmax or Oann
can make the case that they are the real pro-Trump
pro.
Denial outlet and Fox's audience turns to
them instead.
What is the landscape, by the way, right now
of what we would consider the biggest competitors
to to Fox in the context in which I asked
that is one in which many of us in this business
we know about Newsmax.
Newsmax has chosen to stream live 24 seven,
I believe, on YouTube.
They're also on a number of cable systems.
Oann famously has had issues where I think
they've been they've been non renewed by DirecTV
and maybe one other.
I don't think you Oann is currently on YouTube
and that may be because they were kicked off,
although the details sort of escape me at
this point.
What what does the competitive landscape look
like right now?
Yeah, that's definitely an issue.
I mean, I think, you know, the TV landscape
is, I think, less robust, if anything, than
it was during the 2020 election cycle.
You had both Newsmax and Oann as, as you mentioned,
losing access to some cable systems being
generally less available to the public at
the same time, as the TV audience deteriorates,
some of the digital and streaming options
have gotten stronger.
So you see outlets like The Daily Wire or
The Blaze are picking up some steam and those
are competing for the same audience.
If not showing up in the Nielsen ratings or
what have you.
And what's the deal with Real America's Voice?
I see clips very often, but it's not clear
to me whether it does that even have a cable
channel that is available.
Aside from whether anyone's carrying it or
is it online only?
It's mainly online.
I think there's some cable availability, but
not a ton.
That said, no, as cord cutting continues to
be a real business imperative for these networks.
Streaming does become somewhat more viable
and important.
So let's shift a little now and talk about
the primary coverage that we've seen of the
Republican primary.
My assessment right now, and you'll be able
to give us some kind of more fine tuned assessment
was that before the news of the looming arrest
of Donald Trump, it seemed as though Fox News
was sort of creating a little bit of space
for themselves in the direction of Ron DeSantis.
There were some, you know, men on the street,
aka Brian KILMEADE, in a diner, segments that
seemed tailored to find people that that wanted
Ron DeSantis to run.
They did Some actual man on the street segments
were like seven of the eight people they included
in the segment said that they want to Santos
there.
Steve Doocy has been sporadically a little
bit more critical of Donald Trump, and it
sort of seemed like it was a soft escape hatch.
So if it's the Santos, they have a credible
path to have access, but if it's Trump, they
can kind of revert back and maintain the access
that they want.
We were talking before the interview.
You said that that may have shifted back a
little bit since the news of the looming arrest
of Trump.
Yeah, I think what we tend to see with Fox
and Trump is they often have these sorts of
squabbles where the network will try to create
a little bit of distance.
Trump will lash out at the network for not
being supportive enough, but in the end, they
always come back to one another because their
relationship is so valuable to both of them.
Because Fox is a very effective propaganda
tool for Trump, and Trump has a real hammerlock
on the Fox viewership.
And so when we had we had a similar sort of
sense that Fox and the broader Murdoch universe
were trying to break away last year.
But then the FBI raid on Mar a Lago really
sent the Fox hosts back into Trump's corner
and news that an indictment may be pending
for Donald Trump has created a similar situation.
You have FOX hosts like Sean HANNITY and Tucker
Carlson really rallying around the former
president, saying that any indictment of him
is an attack on his supporters, which obviously
means their viewers, that it would be un-American
and a sign that we're in a banana republic.
So, you know, they're certainly not planning
on using any indictment as a way to bolster
some other candidate in his stead.
It really seems like they've they've fully
committed back to his side right now.
How should we expect the primary to go, assuming
Trump stays in it and that the arrests slash
indictments don't don't lead to him dropping
out?
If there is a real contested primary here,
should we expect some version of what we've
been seeing throughout until it becomes clear
who is likely to be the nominee or since Donald
Trump continues to?
A poll so strongly at this point in time,
is it likely that there will be some kind
of of shift?
I'm trying to think of what what we should
expect as far as that goes.
Yeah, I mean, Trump's polling has strengthened
considerably since late last year when it
really looked like DeSantis was making a run.
And you could see the possibility that there
would be a sort of coalescing around him.
But if that doesn't really happen, if DeSantis
fades and it's Trump with 50 to 60% in the
polls against a bunch of people with, you
know, 10% or less, it's really hard to imagine
the various tentacles of the right wing not
coming back under his his wing.
I mean, he's going to have so much of the
energy at that point that it will become sort
of business imperative for them like it was
after he became the nominee in 2016 to find
a way to be on his side.
What do you make of the potential impact of
the Dominion suit?
Because from a business standpoint, there
are some pieces that argue, yeah, it's quite
possible that Rupert Murdoch's going to have
to cut a pretty large check, but he can do
that and it won't really have an impact on
the network.
Maybe there will be part of an agreement.
Could be this is all hypothetical that some
number of corrections need to be issued on
air or something like that.
We've seen that in other situations.
Situations, but maybe not.
Do you think that the actual outcome, aside
from the fact that the texts were released
and now we know what's in them, will impact
Fox News's viewership one way or the other?
I don't know about its viewership.
I do think that on the business side, things
could get very dicey if Rupert Murdoch has
to cut a very large check over this.
There's going to be, I think, a substantial
push from other shareholders to sue the network
for various malfeasance cases.
I think that's going to pose a real problem
for Murdoch going forward, assuming that he
does have to write that check.
And, you know, that's always it's sort of
tricky to make predictions around defamation
lawsuits, though Obviously, this does seem
pretty strong as they go.
When it comes to just more generally coverage
of the Biden administration.
It seems almost like there are enclaves on
Fox News where you see the sort of more conspiratorial
elements of it, which seem to be the nighttime
shows.
Sean HANNITY, Laura Ingram, a lot more Hunter
Biden talk and sort of this sort of thing.
Daytime, I see a lot more sort of what I would
call contrived controversies that when you
look at the story, you and I probably go,
why is that even a story?
But it's like minor things about Joe Biden
or Kamala Harris did or didn't say or go to
a particular place.
And they should have.
It seems sort of more that style of criticism
of Biden during the daytime news Is my perception
of that split accurate?
What do we expect the coverage of Biden to
look like over the next couple of years?
I think what we've run into at this point
is that the interest on the right for any
sort of policy discussion has really just
fallen off of a cliff.
Yes.
Looking back at what Fox was like in 2009
or 2010, you had the sort of Tea Party push
for lower spending, lower taxes and so on
and so forth.
And that kind of discussion of domestic policy
just doesn't happen anymore.
Instead, it's been replaced with various controversies
about woke public schools and these kind of
very minor, very specific events that they
can dig up from local news and fit into their
broader narratives.
And so that's that's really what I expect
to see more of in the next couple of years.
I think they're very bored with Joe Biden
and the Biden administration that they have
not really bothered to create much of a narrative
against him and that that is going to have
a very particular impact on the Republican
presidential primary, because if they don't
need to talk about major economic policy issues,
they're just not going to.
Yeah, there's been sort of an air of like,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
Joe Biden's old and he's woke and he's confused
and Hunter Biden is probably a problem.
But did you see what happened at this drag
show in Tulsa, Oklahoma or something like
that?
And that actually does seem to be far more
interesting to their viewers at.
This point.
Yeah.
And it's the sort of thing where they've trained
their viewers to want a very particular thing
from the news.
And now that's all the viewers want.
It's frankly, it's pretty bad for the Republican
Party that this is the case because it's leading
them to be just completely unable to discuss
issues that the broad scope of the American
populace wants to know about.
Yeah, it's an opportunity for Biden If he
can get news of what he is doing to these
folks.
But, you know, yesterday on my show, we talked
about the money being released for the $30
a month broadband credits, as well as adding
some drugs to the Medicare Part B inflation
indexing list like this is really tangible,
good stuff that hits people's pocketbooks,
but you're not going to hear about it if you're
a primary Fox News viewer.
And so I guess that becomes the question mark.
I think it's less of an issue about reaching
those Fox viewers than it is that the message
that Republicans are going to make to the
overall body of voters is going to be incomprehensible
to them because it is so finely tuned for
Fox viewers.
They just don't have anything to say about
the the broad scope of domestic policy.
That's super interesting.
We're going to be watching that very closely.
We've been speaking with Matt Gertz, who's
a senior fellow at Media Matters.
Matt, really appreciate your time and your
insights today.
Great to be here.